and uh let's get into this first story
from timcast.com netflix adds
anti-censorship section to corporate
culture memo quote if you'd find it hard
to support our content breadth netflix
may not be the best place for you the
streaming service has advised employees
and that's and that's really it that's
the that's the big
smack in the face the document it's
their culture it's their
corporate culture memo whatever
guidelines was originally a 125 slide
presentation created by co-founder reed
hastings to regulate the company without
a traditional corporate structure now
it's called netflix culture seeking
excellence and they're basically saying
they've added an anti-censorship portion
to it and
everybody basically assumes about dave
chappelle netflix dumps a ton of money
on one of the most prominent if not the
mo the greatest comedian of all time or
at least he's the goat right
they're going to make a lot of money on
this and their own employees hurt their
business but you know what else they did
if you watched the dave chappelle
special
i forgot which one was called not the
closer it was the one before this where
he makes the uh sticks and stones i
think it was six and so where he has
this he has that funny bit where he's
like ladies if you can kill it i can at
least abandon it
stuff like that so he also you know
imitated a chinese person and a very
offensive stereotype he went he went for
it
the closer was basically him clearly
you know ruffled up he was basically
defending himself the whole time like
why are people yelling at me so netflix
was like wow
that was not that good they cost us
money if you don't like it get out i
feel like at the corporation there
should be something in their contracts
where if you speak out against the
company
i don't know if every corporation knows
it but that you have there's a recourse
that you can be fired again with no no
bailout package or anything
uh if they don't have that they maybe
they should consider putting that into
their contracts for their employees and
secondly jeremy hamby the quartering
said this earlier today he's reporting
on this as well that they're about to do
a mass layoff i mean they just lost
massive amounts of money they're about
to lay people off so if they can get
them to quit they don't have to pay them
unemployment you know what story i
really love is when there's a company i
used to work for that
uh i left and a bunch of employees i
knew they were like we're going to
unionize and i said you realize that
company doesn't make any money right
like it's all investment there's no
profit so if you're getting paid off of
someone else's money and you're not
making any money for them and then you
go to the boss and say i want more money
he's gonna be like get out you're fired
there's no negotiating when you don't
make any money and they don't believe me
they're like no we're gonna get raises
and benefits and i was like dude you
need to go right now and tell them
that you don't want to be a part of that
you love your job and you'll look for
any opportunity within any of the sister
networks and then sure enough what ends
up happening is they all come and say we
want to unionize and they were like
everyone's fired 300 people just gone
i look my attitude for uh for most
people is like feel unionized if you
want to you know back then i was just
like but just keep in mind what your
negotiating power is
so when you have when you have netflix
here's why i bring this up
these employees
stomp their feet stage walkouts protest
the company they work at what do you
think is going to happen when it comes
time for layoffs like the growth is not
infinite there will come a time when
netflix is hurting netflix is hurting
and they're gonna be like okay we gotta
lay off ten percent of the company who
should we start with um how about all of
the people that were complaining causing
us bad press and weren't doing their
jobs yeah so this is a classic case of
uh the squeaky wheel getting the grease
for sure and in this instance it's not
something positive this is where you're
like trying to figure out all right who
needs to go who needs to go who needs to
go oh right you you were complaining
about this guy who's gonna make us a ton
of money you can get out don't want you
anymore very much in case of flying too
close to the sun feeling very entitled
to everything that netflix has to offer
and like they have to bow to you they
don't turns out which i think is great
yeah that's a good point i obviously
think collective bargaining can be a
great thing but people have to consider
the value that they're bringing to the
table as well as how profitable the
company they're working for actually is
because oftentimes it does happen that a
business will run without making
anything and the company's completely
sponsored by other people's money or by
loans and so they really can't afford to
give people more sometimes it also
happens to be the case that profit
margins for certain industries are just
razor thin and what you actually have to
do to make more than that is pick a
different industry yeah
and i'm i'm a little bit concerned that
these people are going to go to other
industries and bring the same horrible
mindset and that these industries are
going to count out to them just like
they have in the past well a little bit
concerning but who knows you know what's
gonna happen is netflix is gonna write
um amazing recommendations for all of
these employees they wanna get rid of
please and it's gonna be like they were
so good but you know with the downsizing
it's unfortunate i wish we didn't have
to let them go
and then some other company is going to
be like well it looks like everybody
really liked you you're hired suckers
recommendations are such a tricky thing
right because landlords will also
recommend people that they just want to
get rid of to other landlords yeah
they're great no they pay their rent on
time they're never allowed they don't
make a mess of the place
that's a good point i had to give a
recommendation one time and i was like
i'm gonna tell the truth about this
person they should not hire this mf this
person was not good and i don't know if
that person got the job or not but i was
like you need to know what you're
getting into you did the right thing i
think so i think so i don't know yeah
it's your i think it's your
responsibility as a business owner to be
honest about your employees behavior
it's just such a case of social justice
for them to just be like oh we're going
to say super nice things about them so
wherever they end up working that
person's going to be blindsided but by
freaking activism it's not helpful to
any workplace well yeah go well go broke
yeah also and again i mean whenever
you're dishonest it's going to cause
problems and if you're dishonest about
something like that you're actually
doing the person more harm than good
because if you're being dishonest with
the people who you're sending them to
there's a higher probability that you
were also being dishonest with them when
you were expressing potential problems
or failing to and so you've deprived
them of an opportunity to grow
this is this is obviously mostly about
dave chappelle yeah but i also just you
know warn people cuties had a big
backlash too and if netflix is really
saying oh we're not gonna get rid of
this we're gonna artistic expression is
so important
yeah that's that's what they were
claiming about cuties where they were to
produce the movie they actually trained
little girls to do sexual dancing that's
like you shouldn't you shouldn't do that
and they also have big mouth which is
just the weirdest show
i don't understand that show can
somebody who's seen it explain it to me
like what's the truth i don't want to
say it you just don't want to say it
like okay it's about children having sex
there you go yeah it's like it's like 12
year olds experiencing puberty but it's
like overly sexualized there's a demon
that sits on the kid's shoulder that's
like a sex demon i've only seen it once
that's real yeah that's really
disturbing and there's and there's overt
sex and like sexual acts with little
kids how is that allowed high school
kids seriously i mean south park south
park had a few jokes like that in its
run like a handful but this is a show
just based about that like that's all it
is but you know i guess the one thing is
south park never sh like
south park has done some really over the
over-the-line jokes of course but this
show i remember uh i was hanging out
some dudes at some party and they had
netflix on and the show was on
and then i'm like what is this and then
i'm watching it
i don't even want to say i i don't even
think for a family-friendly show i can
explain what they showed like i can't
say it well
there was materials that were shown from
a male
like on a child and i'm just like i
i don't know why you guys are watching
this what is this
that's like not even edgy that's just
full-on perversion that's disgusting
jail
jail yeah that's why i'm like netflix
censor that one yeah i i don't always
agree with you tim but it's one of those
shows man when i walked into the room my
friend was watching and i was like this
is
ridiculous why and i walked out i
wouldn't let myself be near it while it
was on it was disturbing i'd be willing
to bet that if we showed on the on on
this show a clip from big mouth
we'd get taken out we get taken down so
this strikes me as genderqueer the show
because you can't read that in front of
a school board meeting and they're like
oh please shut up we have kids at home
watching this so if you were to show
this on you know youtube they'd be like
oh my gosh you cannot show that well
it's on netflix there was one
controversy where youtube netflix
uploaded a clip from the show that shows
two pre-pubescent girls fully nude what
walking through a bath house with a
bunch of other naked women that are all
singing and dancing about being naked
and what what they argued was no no it's
good because it's body positivity it's
like to teach little girls to like their
bodies and i was just like
i don't know if you need to actually
show all of this you know to to
give someone a message about it it seems
like an excuse
i mean you want to teach little kids
about their bodies that's the parent's
job you put a tv show with little girls
parading around 47 year old men are
going to be watching it too
yeah that pisses me off i feel like with
netflix though
they get so much flack from everybody
like they get flak from everything that
they do they're getting flags so they're
telling the employees like if you guys
say anything it's going to add because
they lost so much money with their their
stock value and all of that so it's like
don't come out don't even with the
twitter stuff it's like the the
the inflated numbers i feel like they're
trying to keep people from doing uh
whistle blowing or doing anything that
could potentially have an impact because
they're so sensitive to bad press right
now
and i i think it's just a weak move i
guess
yeah the free speech argument is there
like oh these employees should be able
to say whatever they want about their
parent company you know what they are
legally they are but the company has the
right to fire them and if you don't like
where you're working and you want to
complain about that company publicly
then you probably shouldn't be working
there well yeah i mean also it's one of
these things where
you can
have conversations with people who are
above you in the company or voice or
criticisms within it is sort of a
strange thing to go outside of the
organization and start trashing at that
point it's like why are you working
there why do you work for these people
you think are horrible are you doing
something to try to change it on the
inside and if that's not working again
why are you still there i feel like it's
a
to me that raises all kinds of red flags
like if you're telling
outside people that you hate the company
what are you doing during your company
hours that could potentially like are
you taking away stealing information are
you not doing your job like you're
supposed to are you eating up your hours
like that's to me to me i feel well a
lot of the contracts that you sign the
companies as well
they're like you have to go through um
our public relations uh office you can't
if the media reaches out to you you
can't talk to them right the social
media policies so
i mean it makes sense um i just it's
sort of like something that i guess
people never thought the companies would
actually follow through
but i guess netflix is like
honestly i'm glad that they are because
people have gotten so unprofessional i
don't care where i work i work for a lot
of different places i had a lot of
horrible work experiences never complain
about the company that i work for nor
should you thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you